foreign
[Music]
have you ever
felt that when you are in your own house
cooking for yourself that you feel
too comfortable
so comfortable that you might end up
with a sad language well this happens to
me too
but if my husband joins the party
it totally taco night
and of course when you have more help in
the kitchen
the result is much better
sadly obviously this is not always the
case
because working as a team can be
challenging too
just imagine a good group of friends
trying to cook together
they are used to different things they
are used to use different tools
and if they are not all in the same page
it could be a disaster
well this often happens when you put
data engineer sorry data professionals
and infrastructure Engineers to work
together
but if they speak the same language they
are said to build successful products
in this talk I'm going to tell you
or discuss with you some of the best
practices that you could follow when
building Chinese applications
and some of some of the challenges that
you may face when working with
interdisciplinary teams when you want to
deploy some applications to the cloud
Dominguez the engineer manager at pixel
a pixel we have several themes and I've
had the opportunity to work in two of
them the data science and analytics and
cloud computing
and these two teams often collaborate
together when building direct products
and the story that I'm going to tell you
is about these themes very first shiny
application
I broken down this story in three parts
product conception development time and
going to the cloud
in each of those parts I'm going to tell
you some of the challenges that we face
and how we overcome them and spoiler
alert we should have gone to the cloud
from the beginning
let's start with the product conception
the first question that you that we ask
is how we are going to collaborate
given that we came from the data
analysis that we were doing individually
well now we needed to code together you
may know the answer so I'm just going to
say it we just get
some of the team members
were learning about git they have to
push and pull code well luckily
we had this plugin in our studio
that is the learning curve because it
can be tricky sometimes
and why use git well
you want to be able to share your code
integrate everyone's contribution and
keep different versions of your code
this is on your local but also in the
git platform and you can use any git
platform like gitlab or GitHub or
bitbucket in our case we ask the
infrastructure team which was a better
tool because what we wanted to do
is just
focus on the development and not worry
too much about the hosting
so we wanted some pipelines automation
that we were when where we were able to
push our code
and then it was going to be deployed to
the cloud
so they chose gitlab because of the
continuous integration and continuous
development features
so in this way they were able to use it
the tool that they felt more comfortable
with while we were using the tool that
we were comfortable with our studio
then we started using Golem
Golem is a shiny framework to build
production level robust shiny
applications
at the beginning I was in very sold on
using this tool because it will add a
lot of our packages and Scaffolding code
that I wasn't very sure that we were
need indeed but then I really liked it
it says you
a very basic wear application where we
can you can build on the top of it and
one of the things that it ads for
example is kind of uh like these scripts
that it will
get you from the step step by step guide
you step by step so you can start
building your
your shiny up
for example uh it will help you uh
configure your application name your
unit testing
you're a favicarn and then you will take
you to the next step so it is a very
nice tool and I highly recommend using
Golem or a framework like this one
especially if this is your first shiny
application
dependency management
this is a concept that if you're not
very used to it it can be hard to
understand it but it is very useful so
we have
um we were facing the issue that maybe
my code was working on my local but it
wasn't working on another team member
the environment and that's because they
didn't have their package set it was
needed or maybe they have it but it was
an older version that was wasn't
supporting the function that I had so
for that you want to use a tool like a
dependency management tool and there are
several options you might as well just
use another script that will hold your
list of dependencies or there are more
sophisticated options like background or
rmp whatever the option you you choose
try to do it see from the beginning
so you won't have to do some reverse
engineering remember all the tools that
you have installed and then add it to
the dependency management tool
if you do it from the beginning you
won't have that problem
also it is okay to explore and innovate
or they are packages that are out there
but for your application just add the
tools that you really need for your
application to run
so when it is on the cloud you are going
to use
package Joseph the the dependencies that
you need so
just keep it simple every
package that you
add is is used potential bugs or issues
are more maintaining so it's a good idea
to keep it simple
at this point we were ready for the
development time so everything is
already set up so we were ready to build
our product
so how we were going to distribute the
workload well Golem helps you to create
these shiny modules you can think of
them as many shiny applications that you
are going to call from the main script
in our case we had five dashboards so we
created one shiny module per dashboard
and we distributed them among the team
members the way that you are going to
separate the work is going to depend on
your use case your application or your
team members
integrating the back end so this is how
we did it
we collected the data and created some R
data frames
then we loaded them into an sqlite
database which is a file
and then set up the database connection
we create all the queries that we needed
and then connect them
connect those results to our dashboard
charts
but that wasn't real data it was just
like sample data so we needed to really
be collecting data on a daily basis we
needed to build some data pipelines and
then loading that data
into an Amazon redshift and then
delete it all over again so where is the
recommendation here well
connect to your database from the
beginning even if that database does not
contain all the production code it can
be sample data but it is very important
that you start building your product
thinking that is going to be in the
cloud and then it's going to be in
production
keep it secure
so at the beginning we were this is very
bad I know but we wear hard coding
passwords AWS keys and sensitive
information so what happened
every time that we were pushy database
credentials
we needed to go to that database that
was already compromised and changed the
credentials
but what if we had push some sensitive
information that we cannot really change
well you need to go to git and remove
that from
from your code but get one of the main
features is that you are going to keep
several versions of your code so even
let's say that we are talking about the
password even if the latest version does
not contain that password
you can just go back to the previous
commit and the password is going to be
there so you have to go all the way back
to the hit history where that password
is present and remove all those commits
from the git history
and by doing that you are going to
remove some production code so it's
going to be a mess so how to solve that
well use environment variables
you can use this.r environment file
that's going to be kept in your in your
local that's going to have these key
value pairs
and you're going to call the keys
uh in your code like so
and not only is going to be secure but
it's going to be ready for the cloud as
well because what if you have a database
per environment those credentials are
going to be different it doesn't matter
because your code is already prepared
it's only using the keys the values are
different in the in every environment so
the only thing that you need to tell
your infrastructure Engineers are what
are
the variables the environment variables
that you need so your application run
and they are going to set up with
something similar to that
now going to the cloud this is a moment
of truth because what you want at this
point is just push your code and hope it
it runs you want to build release and
run well this is rare that it happens
the first time and for us it didn't
happen like the first 10 times
so how we solve that what we did is that
every time we were doing a commit we
were validating that commit
gitlab has
these nice pipelines where you can add
some step to validate the code that it
has been pushed so for example you what
you can do is
the first step install the dependencies
package your application electing this
was a the selling point for me about the
Golem because I wasn't really sure about
using it
and and when I saw that June Golem needs
to package your application and then run
it it was weird to me because I was
thinking like a package like diplar or
ggplot that those are there for you to
use it and I didn't want my application
to be out there but don't think it like
that
when you package your application what
it will happen is that it will run or
you all your code
so that means that if you forgot to add
a dependency it's going to fail
if you forgot to remove some line of
posts that they didn't have to be there
it's going to fail but if it can be
packaged then it means that every line
of code is a working line
so that's um that's a very good step for
quality assurance
and then run your unit test
you can validate the presence of a title
a legend or a button just to know that
your dashboard is up and running
also have a development Cloud
environment
these are an environment that is meant
to be
broken just for you to break and
if it is not broken then it means that
you can push it to production and this
is especially important when you already
went live and you can also have like a
middle environment like studying or
validation where it's going to be an
exact replica of your production
environment and you can run some
end-to-end testing there just to be sure
that all the functionality is there
so those are some of the best practices
that you can follow and of course there
are more I will say that one of the
biggest ones was the communication
between the infrastructure engineers and
the and the data team
so I really
recommend you to get familiar with all
these Concepts and I promise you that
that communication will get easier
remember this group of friends that are
in somebody else's kitchen it might feel
weird at the beginning
but but once they agree on the terms
that they are going to be collaborating
how they are going to collaborate the
workouts easier and they can start
working in Harmony and having fun and
most importantly have great results
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]